foreign
and I'm really excited for the episode
today in actuality I'm not just saying
that to pump you all up to keep
listening I was going through everything
and I'm like oh yeah these are some
things I really want to talk about
organized in a fun manner so that I can
present them to you and keep that
enthusiasm going my only
worry is that I won't get to everything
right you may notice I'm going free solo
right now I do not have a computer in
front of me because I realize sometimes
when I have the computer next to me I
have it on a screen in front of here but
then I'll go I'll look over here and
it's kind of distracting it ruins that
connection that I have and takes me out
of my thought process sometimes so for
the first time I'm going to be trying to
rely just on the monitor right for the
outline that I have because yes this is
not off the top of my head I outline
stuff but most of it's off top of my
head speaking of free solo
Casey says free solo is one of the best
movies he's ever seen and I intended to
see this movie I know everyone Hypes it
up but
there's a lot to dissect there maybe
once I watch it we can come back but
Casey you you've actually seen it five
times I've seen it five times yeah if I
like something I'll watch it a bunch
it's amazing
just to see somebody like super like
singleness of purpose just like this is
all he's about he wants to be the best
at this one thing he yeah you know
climbs lcap El Capitan with no ropes no
nothing oh God that's crazy and just the
way they were able to
cover the way they were able to shoot it
like just as impressive
maybe not as impressive as the feet
itself but insane yeah and my only point
of reference for that is I was in Costa
Rica around this time last year and
there was a rock climbing wall and like
I tried the you know it was like the
beginner one and then like this slightly
harder one so I'm like I can do the
slightly hard one and I did but like not
that it was that hard but there was like
points where it like kind of come just
curves out a little bit you're like oh
my God this is so scary the idea of like
hanging and not being able to Lean
Forward on something and even just
whatever it was probably
30 to 40 feet high Max and it feels like
so much more you know kind of like on
the high dive like you look at these
platforms like oh it's only 30 feet up I
can go up there and look down it's it's
just most people have this Natural
Instinct like people go I'm scared of
heights it's like yeah I'm also scared
of tigers attacking me you know it's
like it's a rational
fear to have it's not I wouldn't really
consider that a phobia you'd almost it's
the exception that people don't have
this extreme phobia and so this guy like
my next questions would be
as far as inquiry into the movie like
there's something going on with this
guy's brain right that makes him
different either naturally or it's funny
that you say that because of the
producers asked that same question and
actually he went to a like a neurologist
yeah and they're like see this part of
your brain that like uh would elicit
some fear response yeah it's like
nothing right in the same way that you
can look at a brain scan of a psychopath
and go oh this part of your brain that
would experience anxiety and maybe
there's an overlap there because part of
being a psychopath is like you literally
don't feel anxiety so you know imagine
the things that you could do especially
crime if you didn't feel any sort of
anxiety
or empathy or remorse right so those
parts of your brain are and I don't know
if like the you know again the
difference being
between a psychopath and a sociopath a
sociopaths are said to be like made by
circumstance
and psychopaths are born that's one
Theory but
you can look at somebody's brain and
determine that so I wonder if there must
be an overlap right
um but it's just such an abnormality
that you would be able to do that not be
you know paralyzed with fear so I guess
that's why he's the only person doing it
or if you you know if you were to look
at like Elite stuntmen or I don't know
Casey Garrity like what you know
there must be something
going on in in probably a degree to
which you can train that like when Hoff
you know the guy who does all the ice
water stuff like that you see how you
know this is trainable it's extremely
uncomfortable but you can both acclimate
and also just teach and I think about
that like when I go into a cold bath
it's almost like you can make the
decision to be like I'm going to calm my
body down I'm going to stop being
jittery and it works to some degree I'm
not saying you can instantly become this
master but it's like that's a skill to
get better at and even I've been
noticing that in the sauna and I'm going
to continue to preach going into the sun
I've been trying to do it more after
each workout even in the place of cardio
sometimes just because it works out
better but I
like I noticed that when people say
oh it's really hot outside I notice it
less than I know that's very subjective
and it's gonna like well I'm in such
good shape I remember my friend told me
one time I'm in such good shape I don't
even sweat anymore and I'm like sir
you're obese you know but it was one of
these guys who's like fat and always was
always like making stuff up to brag or
whatever but there is this element I do
feel like I've acclimated to heat in a
way that I'm just more comfortable in
extreme heat I know it can go the other
way and I have to assume there's an
element of like
you know acclimating yourself to extreme
stress if you do it in a progressively
overloading I found a way to bring it
back
being amazing but yeah I would love to
watch this and come back and kind of
you know the other question I had case
is if you've watched this five times
there has to be like because any movie
that I watched more than once
I go there's a like there's a deeper
meaning to it so what resonates with you
like on a deeper level
a singular Focus thing yeah definitely
yeah that's just my takeaway it almost
it reminds me of uh and it's a phrase
that I think Conor McGregor has said
like a singleness of purpose just like
being hyper focused on one goal
obviously yeah it will have a detriment
on other facets of your life but that's
a sacrifice that he was willing to make
and that's why he's amazing I heard that
quote recently and I don't know if I'd
heard it before but it you know it
definitely
made me think and I think there's a lot
of guys who
you know who have done incredible things
Steve Jobs or whatever I don't know it's
debatable like you know Steve Jobs don't
look for people Steve Jobs didn't even
know how to program but you know
whatever Eve I'll give credit for that
even just the driving Vision
um you know and being the engine behind
something if not the actual you know
mechanistic Parts all right somebody
sent me this and I thought it was
interesting enough to start off with it
it's going to be a a sauce you're not on
Mark Wahlberg now
he's an interesting case and actually
looking at him previously
um I actually thought about
how
my operating assumption was that he was
on steroids if for example in the movie
uh pain or gain he looks bigger now he
doesn't necessarily look that lean now
that I think about it I have my mental
image now of course the rock looks like
he's on
a a big blast of steroids like he looks
bigger maybe than at any other time I've
seen him and over the years you know
this is why people
can tell he's on steroids is because now
I actually look back at some of his WWE
he looked good in the WWE like I thought
he was fatter than he was but he looked
like he was good he was solid he was
relatively lean but he's become
extremely lean he just has terrible AB
genetics and I think he had like some
rupture in his abs but sometimes you'll
see guys especially Pacific Islanders
not to be racist but their AB insertions
are slightly different
compared to for example you know I saw
this black dude on Tick Tock the other
day and his waist looks like it's 18
inches you know what I mean to do sounds
like perfectly symmetrical abs and it's
like his waist is freakishly small and
that has to be taken into considerate it
looks amazing but it's like you can't
train that you know what I mean you
can't like you could have a surgeon do
certain things to your body but even
then it's totally dependent on like how
wide are your hip bones you know that is
the determining factor in what your
waist ultimately tapers down to so of
course we have genetic limitations Mark
Wahlberg has some pretty amazing
genetics he's always looked really good
uh you know and that's why he was the
face of these underwear ads it's like he
just looks good with a moderate amount
of muscle he was never too big but like
you know he he just had he had a good
like stomach and people loved it and for
51 years old as we've seen this pick
he looks extremely good this guy sent me
this and said Marky Marcus 51 Matt
Stevenson sent me this Mark and Mark is
51 juice question mark I don't know what
he could possibly be referring to when
he says juice but
when I looked at him what's happening
you didn't say anything great okay
I said what'd you say about Marky Mark
you do not pursmirch his good name my
brethren name and I look at him and I go
that's actually achievable so whether or
not he's on steroids my assumption would
be if you're him and you've done
steroids before you could be on trt
or a low dose of HGH and that's kind of
like look if I was a Hollywood celebrity
who made money off having muscle mass
you'd almost be stupid not to but when I
look at this the key factors that I
consider are this is not a guy who was
out of shape for decades and then came
back to it and that's something that I
know you guys may know about my dad is
like he was in really good shape and let
it slide and then got back into shape
like car you like he could swim several
miles when he passed away from a heart
attack
it's just that the damage was done and
you gain certain fat like uh you know
this visceral fat that kind of like
hardened you know fat that you'll see on
guys with big guts and like that have
maybe some other health issues like
diabetes like
that's really hard to reverse but it
comes from you know a decade or two of
letting yourself go completely in some
of those things unfortunately just it's
either impossible or nearly impossible
to reverse so the answer is never get
out of shape so when I look at Marky
Mark I go actually
if you just never let it go
at 51 what's the reason that he can't
have that muscle mass and I've seen
other guys
um Paul sklar for example is a guy who
looks amazing at 51 and people have
accused he's taken all sorts of
uh drug tests and like you also kind of
see like when people talk about it and
address accusations
there's a manner in which I think fake
natties respond and there's a manner in
which guys are like I honestly don't
know anything about steroids respond
because they're almost like they don't
even know what how to answer it you know
they're like look here and I think this
should prove that but mainly a guy like
Paul scar I know is hyper disciplined he
like this doesn't have cheat meals you
know he's like yeah occasionally I'll
have a cookie you know but otherwise
he's like just a a you know portrait of
discipline and he's also like a former
Elite
by athlete not a bisexual athlete guys
get your minds out of gutter somebody
who does running and biking
um and he was uh if not a distance
runner at Wake Forest uh you know some
some painful event either the 18 the 800
to the 1500 something where it's like oh
that hurts at the end right not fun to
do but he's doing it when you have the
type of discipline you need to run a
like anything over a Sprint
in a Collegiate level you know track and
field you're an All-American whatever
that guy has discipline Mark Wahlberg
has discipline so look at this guy and
just go hey if you're in your 20s right
now
start lifting never get out of shape and
when you're in your 50s and 60s you're
going to look great just because you
never let it slip okay so Mark Wahlberg
is he Natty right now he could be on to
the next one here we go sup well okay
now I'm gonna slow things down
after that exciting intro talk about the
Tough Mudder event and mainly so we went
to Rockford Illinois we did this Tough
Mudder I think it's like 9.6 miles 15K
whatever that is correct me if I'm wrong
but
I rolled my ankle in the middle of it
oh no Mark what what crazy obstacle did
you roll your ankle on the dirt that
obstacle the ground beneath my feet uh
there was a divot and it's like you know
you step and you're expecting ground and
then you go further and you just like
you know I fully fell with it
dramatically and screamed you know I was
like
um
but you know like your ankle goes in
that direction you know something
happened but it isn't quite you're like
the inflammation hasn't said in just yet
so I ran the rest of the race it was
probably three plus miles and it was
like I could tell there was like up
something popped and there was like an
acute pain but then later that night it
swells up and it's extremely painful
just like in every position I'm laying
down in the bed and it's painful I'm
stepping on it it's painful I'm getting
ready and I'm packing it's painful
um and normally because I always set up
these things like what's relevant about
this
normally in my life I would be like I'm
gonna baby it right like I've talked
about my back I'm gonna baby I have this
injury I'm gonna not do anything on it
but instead after I flew back
on
um Sunday that Monday I got up and I did
a leg workout like a light leg workout
not really like I did lunges sled pushes
and like a little upper body circuit
really just to like get the blood going
because you know you have to come off
from flying and all this and you know
you may be eating a little bit more on
vacation you want to get uh you know you
want to get your body moving to get some
of those fluids moving that you're
retaining
in doing so oh and a little bit of
StairMaster right which maybe hurts a
little bit because you're essentially
you know the way depending on how you
position your foot it could be a calf
raise on each thing but I noticed much
quicker healing didn't ice it uh did uh
well I did a one little ice bath for
like 20 minutes to reduce the
inflammation
um but outside of that I didn't wrap it
I didn't do anything special to it I
just started moving on it and my
recommendation for you with these kinds
of things is the advice of movement is
medicine if you're injured don't be
scared to do something that isn't it's
not on the threshold of uh continuing to
aggravate the injury but getting blood
into the area and increasing the range
of motion because really that's what
you're dealing with is like that
inflammation is limiting your range of
motion
and if you can loosen some of that up
it's going to start to feel better and
also you're going to get more blood flow
for healing that's it okay oh wait guy
who hit me up this guy
this is relevant this is another one of
these things where
um people hit me up and they have these
questions and I go
that would be easier to answer on the
phone real quick so the other day when
I'm going home from shooting a sketch
with Isaiah after work another Banger I
talked to this guy who had messaged me
basically saying
like his question was so simple and so
or betrayed as sort of basic
understanding when I do these exercises
I've been looking up stuff to do online
I've never lifted before I believe he's
in his 30s or 40s he has a kid and you
know my heart when people when guys are
like I want to get in shape you know for
my family it's like I'm gonna prioritize
that and uh I want to get back to
everybody but like it's like oh man yeah
let's do this even if
you know nothing which is hard it's like
harder to kind of get you on like this
basic understanding uh because there's a
lot to cover but
he sent me his workouts and he was like
here's like nine things I'm doing for
chess because I was like can you tell me
what you're doing his first question was
actually
when I'm seeing all these exercises
listed do you do like a set of the first
one and then the second one and then the
third one and then go back to the top
so like he didn't he wasn't sure that
like the norm is like no no you do your
five sets of bench press then you move
on to flies right
unless you're doing a circuit training
but but it's probably not what you know
when you see a workout online they're
not implying a circuit so I was like
okay so that's where we're at that's
fine let me get on the phone with you
because you're you gave me I'm like
could you also show me what you're what
you're doing and he sent me this like
you know it's a single muscle workout
split so your chest one day back the
next day yada yada
and he was doing like nine things for
chest and my first instinct was to be
like that's stupid you don't need to be
doing that many things like I've done
workouts for months that were very
effective that involved uh
just doing one thing for chest at a time
for example in the DC program any sort
of high intensity low volume protocol
you're not doing very much
but I got on the phone with him and I
had this realization that I should have
asked first
which was do you enjoy doing this that's
the most important thing he answered yes
and I said okay
while you're creating this habit of
daily exercise and you're finding
satisfaction in this thing right that
you set up and you uh you had the
instinct to go look online and you had
the drive to follow through and write it
down and use creativity to implement
this thing that essentially you came up
with derived from other sources but I go
that's inherently satisfying
and if you're getting satisfaction out
of doing that it doesn't matter right
because the minute differences between
like a full body split and an upper body
lower body and push-pull legs and you
know full body five days a week yada
yada
the differences between those things are
much smaller than the difference between
working out and not working out so if
what you're doing keeps you working out
that's probably pretty good for the near
term especially for beginner going into
exercise he's still formulating that
connection of working out is fun uh
working out is something I do I am a guy
who lifts weights I am a guy who works
out every day and if I don't do that I'm
not going to feel as good yada
I'm using the word yada yada a lot okay
I understand that let's make it a joke
for the entire podcast
now the thing we did land on was the
idea of rpe rate of perceived exertion I
do think this is incredibly important
for people to learn
intensity because
he's going oh I'm doing these exercises
and I'm doing make the 12 reps and I go
that's meaningless because you know we
could be using the same weight right 8
to 12 reps of 135 pounds on bench from
uh a guy who would fail at that weight
versus me it's a warm-up versus a set to
failure right like a one to a ten on rpe
so you have to learn
how many sets you're doing within a
certain proximity of failure right you
only need a handful of sets you don't
need 30 sets to failure but you could do
30 sets and a lot of them are some
failure and some of them are two failure
that's really one of the most important
variables is learning like what failure
feels like and how to gauge whether
you're three two one reps away right
that that proximity to failure because
once you gauge that it's like I know I
did 10 sets that were two reps shy of
failure and the next week I'm gonna do
11 sets that were two sets or two reps
shy of failure
once you understand that you can
understand Progressive overload and
adding more volume because you can add
volume but if you're decreasing the
intensity so much it just ends up being
a wash it's meaningless so that was the
one thing that I sent him down on my go
look up this and he hit me back like
y'all I've been researching this all
night blah blah you know I want to set
people on the right path and sometimes
that's just like okay your final you are
here's one new thing go research that
be curious
or bike whatever be curious bi-curious
buy organic no I do think we're on the
same page as far as thinking this is one
of the greatest episodes that I've ever
done and my energy levels are through
the roof and once again
I have one thing that I can credit that
to and that's Kratom from not just any
old Source on the internet but a
specific Source called happy hippo
herbals.com I want you to go there I
want you to
dabble in the online store that they
have provided you and see if you see
anything you like
use promo code fitboy with three c's for
20 off literally every time you go there
I want you to take it I want you to tell
me about it I want you to do your own
research
and tell me what you find because this
is an ongoing discussion every time I
make an ad about how people create them
is another opportunity for you to tell
me about your likes and dislikes or
skepticisms and hopes for this product
promo code thick boy three C's use it or
lose it you're not going to lose it but
it'll be there but just use it if you're
watching an episode of haters will say
you're also watching me in an oak and
stone shirt and if you're listening I'm
sorry that you don't get to see me in an
oak and stone shirt maybe just go to the
YouTube for one second and to see this
long sleeve button up that I don't give
as much love to because guess what it is
summer however it's nice and crispy
inside this office and once again this
stuff's breathable I've been doing this
whole podcast I have not sweat through
it right people have noticed oh yeah the
material
is is very sturdy but it's also
breathable
um I wanted to point out that my
promotion of having people buy an oak
and stone and send me proof of that with
promo code hella get your free phone
consultation that is now over as of
today there will be other promotions in
the future but I wanted to thank
everybody who did that it's really cool
to see you guys buying it and send me
proof of it because they don't always
get like you guys don't always
necessarily send me a screenshot but a
lot of people sent me a screenshot and
I'm uh texting with everybody who
purchased anything if I don't see yours
like if I don't see a DM that you sent
me comment on something because I want
to make sure I get to everybody I just
have a lot of message requests from
people responding to my hilarious memes
so it could possibly get buried but
we're going to follow through on each
one of these consultations uh ideally in
the next couple weeks there's not so
many that I can't bang them out
relatively soon there's not going to be
huge backlog I really look forward to
talking to everybody and I think you're
really going to like the clothes and so
I'm excited about that we're going to do
more Promos in the future sure and
I'm glad that you're using promo code
hella at oakenstoneclothing.com and also
just see Crystal Lee wearing my stuff he
didn't know right I was like hey man
this is some stuff you could wear and
then he took it out of the box like oh
this is actually really nice stuff and
that's I think the reaction that a lot
of people have oh this is really nice
stuff so
check it out promo code hello
new promise in the future bye-bye liver
King who is this guy you keep telling me
about this is actually a clip that I
covered on
I brought up on t-faced so it was
interesting and I'm gonna play it here
right here right now
in this he's asked a good question by
the interviewer
um he goes okay because we weren't
taking penicillin back then there's
interesting things about about this
related to this he's like should we take
medicine basically cute medicine that we
have today right but a lot of the
long-term [ __ ] that we do is to our
detriment like well um so let me let me
tell you this people always make this
criticism oh yeah you're promoting The
ancestral living a lot of early
ancestors live to 30. all right this is
what people say all the time stupid [ __ ]
like this right and here's the fact is
you call what we're doing today living
you call going to a job that you hate
coming home to a life you don't love
putting on Netflix sedating yourself
just enough with medication to get hard
and to be happy call that a day called a
week called a month that's your [ __ ]
life you call that living this is how we
exist today about like medicine and [ __ ]
yeah so the guy says what about medicine
and [ __ ]
people are going to make good content
they have to press the liver King on
you know some of these apparent
contradictions but I actually think he
does a pretty good job
of staying character staying on message
staying on brand and answering these
things in an effective way which is
medicine and he because he's always said
I've heard him say in other interviews
like I take the good from ancestral
living and leave the other BS behind
that BS of you know living in dirt and
dying young but also like the whole like
you know
we all died at 30. it's like that's an
average of things so it's like yeah
there were more you know infant
mortality or more you know deaths by
accident or you you know people getting
eaten by Predators Etc so it averages
out but there were still humans who
lived to 70 or 80 I have to imagine
um but this goes to the notion of
lifespan versus Health span which Dr
Rhonda Patrick talks about uh which is
like okay yeah you live to a hundred
what if the last 30 or 40 Years of your
life are spent with dementia
in a wheelchair
um with some sort of chronic illness
that could have been prevented by taking
more preventative measures and just
being living a healthier life up to that
point right and as he said with acute
medicine like penicillin like you know
you're in an emergency great but it's
this message of like you know instead of
painkillers instead of the things that
we take like antidepressants chronic
medicine
uh that the research even backs up like
you know
the lack of Serotonin is not necessarily
the cause of depression but as far as I
know
you know exercise has been one of the
most fundamental things for me to get
out of the depression so I just you have
to be skeptical of these things where
it's like hey oh the answer to your
problem is to take a pill for the rest
of your life
that is a cliche it's this anti-big
Pharma cliche of like you're trying to
get your hooked on pills but it is true
you know and I like that he
differentiates that modern medicine cool
yeah it can save you in an emergency
um
antibiotics are great uh you get an
infection you get a virus but if we're
talking about the things that
modern medicine claims to be cured with
a pill for the rest of your life try
checking in with the things that you can
do
without medicine
that actually require hard work and
that's why people shy away from them is
because yeah exercise is hard putting
yourself in an uncomfortable position
even self-reflection growth meditation
all these things are like yeah it's
uncomfortable
but you can do it and make yourself
better okay I thought this was
interesting hella personality portion of
the podcast
um this was an article that I thought
was interesting that talks about the
relationship between exercise as a mood
regulation strategy and trait emotional
intelligence so my take away from this
was
because it sounds at first almost like
and I'll read this the purpose is the
abstract the main the aim of this study
was to investigate the relationship
between perception of emotional
intelligence and beliefs in the extent
to which exercising leads to mood
enhancement
um
they completed volunteers completed a 33
item self-report measure of trait
emotional intelligence and an exercise
mood regulation scale so basically they
were measuring two things
how emotionally intelligent you are and
I think that's a really important thing
in society in general and as an
individual you want to develop emotional
intelligence even if that's not
something that comes naturally to you
and that's something that I've tried to
develop over the years that I don't
think I had an abundance of as a young
person
now the second thing they measure is
whether or not you believe that exercise
can be a mood regulation strategy so
they're not looking at it like is
exercise and effective mood regulation
strategy they're looking at people who
have one trait do they believe in
this thing that we know is real or I I
know is real
and what's the connection between the
two and they find that more emotionally
intelligent people
have a much greater tendency to think of
exercise as a mood regulation strategy
um emotional intelligence significantly
correlated with beliefs that exercise
could be used to regulate mood
conclusion findings demonstrate that
using exercise to regulate mood relates
significantly to emotional intelligence
and suggests that individuals who use
exercise to enhance mood
report higher scores of emotional
intelligence
um
and
I guess the deeper insight into that is
like you think about somebody who's
emotionally intelligent and therefore
perhaps more self-aware of their own
emotions in addition to the emotions of
others they're going to recognize when
they're in a bad mood and they're going
to recognize when their mood has changed
after exercise and I realize that may
seem obvious but maybe if you lack
emotional intelligence or you don't
reflect or take note of things and the
causation element of I did this and then
that happened or I felt different right
I realized you can go through life
ignorant of that uh those changes
so it seems obvious but you could be
totally oblivious I've noticed that for
many many years and it's a very real
thing and it's I will always say the
foundation of my reason for exercising
is the mood regulation
um some people don't know you don't want
to be around people who don't understand
why they're in a bad mood
if I'm in a bad mood I try to go like
let me figure this out before I let it
out on people but if you lack emotional
intelligence you're probably more likely
to go like I'm in a bad mood and the
people around me are causing it or I'm
justified in being mean to people
because of my bad mood or making these
decisions that affect other people
negatively or myself negatively because
of this bad mood because it's like
reality it's sort of like people who are
you know suicidal it's like they see it
as a rational Choice like you know the
old well obviously like life is hopeless
and I'm worthless and it's like no no
that's your perception of reality based
on your transient mood right now and
maybe it's been there for a while but
it's hard to imagine breaking out of
that you know because it seems permanent
even though it's not so
that's what I tend to notice when I
suspect somebody has like an emotional
immaturity problem or whatever they kind
of see their moods as like a permanent
state or something that justifies
unethical Behavior you know and then
they're gonna
you know when they're in a better mood
they might make a totally different
decision or have different like
principles of action
that are totally inconsistent and it's
like you become a lot you can't be an
adult and just being like Oh yeah this
is right behavior when I'm in a good
mood but you know
um
you know because you can't hold anybody
accountable that way it's like well I
felt like doing it okay you're a toddler
great
you know I'm gonna do a real quick run
through hella sick Fitness Pages I've
covered Jeff Nipper before but I think
this is a good
little video uh that he made talking
about the worst supplements that people
take do a quick rundown one test
boosters look
there's all sorts of test boosters out
there ashwagandha and Boron and horny
goat weed and all this stuff and he was
basically like look first of all a lot
of these you look at a lot of the
supplements they just have a proprietary
blend it doesn't even tell you how much
of the thing is in there right
um secondly you look at the ingredient
list and like there's a half of them are
compounds that have never even had one
study that verified any increase in
testosterone so like some of them are
unproven and then some of them you look
at it's like okay you know ashwagandha
is maybe the most promising one out of
all those but when you look at the most
charitable study because some studies
would say it does nothing some studies
would say oh it increases test you know
97 nanograms per deciliter but then you
look at how much like you know inject
600 milligrams of testosterone into
yourself and it's going to increase like
almost 2 400 nanograms per deciliter
so just do little steroids right
um but like that's always my point of
view was like hey instead of you know be
like this is probably significantly more
expensive
than just doing trt or something like
that so I'm like you know is 90 maybe 97
nanograms per deciliter is worth it to
you and there are other effects of some
of these like ashwagandha apparently you
know can help alleviate stress but I
have never seen evidence that test
boosters are worthwhile
and but they continue to be pushed
because every guy wants more tests and
it's like have you tried sleeping eight
hours have you tried taking more zinc
and magnesium and vitamin D there's
other ways to go about it a more
effective checklist that costs you
nothing that you should you know lift
heavy sleep more
take zinc magnesium vitamin D for
starters and see what happened
next up is terquestrone he went over how
this is the hottest you think oh people
are always asking about a trickestron
it's an active steroid it's basically
like a plant steroid
um that seemingly doesn't have these
side effects of anabolic steroids there
are studies that suggest that it could
increase your muscle mass quite a bit
but then the controversy of it like like
as as a
side effect free supplement it has a lot
of Promise some of these like Studies
have come out of the USSR and so you
have to translate it from Russian it's
like it's still this black box of a
mystery and I go if you can afford you
know this bottle of turkestrone
and afford that it you know to flush
that money down the toilet because it
potentially does nothing then sure take
it but
if it's you know if 80 is a lot to you
then don't do it and the issue that came
about recently was people going
uh lab testing this stuff
and finding out that like there's less
than one percent of what they say is in
there you know like each pill contains
500 milligrams of trachestrone or ecti
steroids and then they
according to you know Advanced
Laboratory Testing techniques and Jeff
nippert is he has a degree in
Biochemistry so like when he says some
of this stuff it's like you know he
knows better than me at least uh whether
these
uh whether their approach to testing
would be legitimate or not and he's like
it see it looks good to me and they're
finding one percent you know like what
if you
you know you buy a rain energy a rain
body Fuel and it says uh you know 300
milligrams of caffeine and you found out
there's actually two milligrams of
caffeine you'd be pissed that is not
delivering on the promise of what's in
there so until we can even verify that
this is you know there's the correct
dosing you have no idea
BCAAs is the next one and I always
thought like you know if you're eating a
complete protein you don't need BCAAs
it's a huge thing though that people
harp on and and he goes into depth more
of like each individual one what you
need to gain muscle and how like
actually taking taking some of them in
conjunction might interfere with the
other ones that you're taking so it's
like it's one of these ones that looks
good on paper
like yeah okay you get BCAAs from
protein and maybe you're fasting and you
take BCAAs which simply would argue is
not fasting but it's just something like
I've had fantastic results with never
taking BCAAs maybe when I was in high
school I took them but I just think it's
totally non-essential fat burners he
talks about because when you look at you
know a thermogenic fat burner like the
old Xenadrine or any sort of caffeine
um
clenbuterol even comes to mind which is
not necessarily legal but not you know
classified in the same way that some
other things are
diet and exercise are always going to
Trump that right so if people are
looking at this magic pill of a
thermogenic fat burner it's like have
you tried diet and exercise okay studies
showed that there's really not a
substantial difference between that
unless there's an appetite suppressant
element to it but that goes away you
know if you take a bunch of ephedra you
know cool might work for 10 to 14 days
but your body acclimates to it really
quickly you got to keep upping the dose
and then it just stops working okay and
the final one was beta alanine which is
said to reduce lactic acid in the body
but not in the range that most people
work out it was like an exercise bouts
of one to four minutes it suppresses
lactic acid burn to allow you to keep
exercising but like in if you're doing
eight reps it's probably not even a
minute long so keep that in mind most
things that you're going to be sold at
GNC are ineffective in a waste of money
this brings me to a lot of people been
asking me segment that has a
relationship the last thing that we
covered
semaglutide
and that's a new compound that
uh people have been asking me about
because it's very promising in the realm
of fat burning
what it is my loose understanding and to
to to set this up so basically there's
two hormones that control hunger in your
body ghrelin and lectin
agrelein is the hormone that causes
hunger and lectin is the hormone that
makes you feel satiated or full so
somaglitized from what I understand it
suppresses or uh yes it it suppresses
the ghrelin hormone to make you hungry
so you're essentially just never really
hungry in that instinctual way I don't
think it makes you feel like oh gross
maybe if you take too much of it
apparently you know you can get nauseous
from it but it's really interesting
because all these other things they get
at that hunger Instinct in an indirect
way right like if you're taking a
stimulant my understanding is that
you're doing this you know it's it's
signaling to your adrenal system your
adrenergic system
um Pathways to make you feel like I'm in
an emergency I don't need food right
because when you're really stressed
stout or whatever like you're not going
to be hungry but eventually that wears
off because your body always wants this
homeostasis now to a degree with smag
glutide you start out at a 0.25 per week
dose it's a weekly injection and then
we'll get up to
um you know one or two milligrams I
think is where it tops out like 2.4
milligrams of red but
it's something that gets right at the
heart of things because everything else
is like oh we're going to increase your
body temperature we're going to increase
your heart rate we're gonna you know it
stimulate you in some way or you know
even growth hormone you know acts to
increase lipolysis uh the burning of fat
throughout the day as a fuel source but
you can easily outdo that
if you're in you know if you get hungry
and you eat a caloric Surplus right
because it's like it's only a maybe a
few hundred calories a day that this can
account for of fat
um the growth hormone pathway
so it's very promising
I have some people who are interested in
taking it I've talked to some people
online
um who are getting it through uh more
plates more dates uh online clinic and
you can ask for when I've read some
reviews online seems really promising so
out of anything that I've ever seen this
could possibly be the thing that people
are looking for and I hear that like a
lot of women in you know Beverly Hills
Calabasas Etc they're swearing by you
can go to your doctor now they're going
to overcharge you for it right probably
by 10 to 20 times which you could get it
for on an online health clinic or on the
dark web or whatever so look into
competitive pricing but like you know if
you go to a doctor in Beverly Hills yeah
they're going to charge you you know
several thousand a month probably but if
this is something you really strong
struggle with because if you're
chronically obese your hunger hormones
are going to be off so if you can
control that directly
there might be hope for your fat ass
um next up we got you know another lot
of people been asking me uh if we could
scroll down to the real Cool Hand Luke
hit me up and I told him I'd answer this
question on the podcast today he said
hey man I was wondering if you had some
advice for bulking I'm 19 years old six
one and 202 pounds
that sounds you know roughly like me
when I was like 16 years old in high
school like I remember it was a big deal
for me to get over 200 pounds is it
possible to getting 20 pounds of muscle
on a clean bulk or do I just need to
focus on bulking and then go on a cut
after to lean down I went from making
this all about me I went from 189 pounds
wrestling my junior year so I was like
up to 200 for football and then I cut
down to 189 to wrestle my junior year
and then I got up to like 220 by the end
of uh the summer for football
was that all muscle no
um was I particularly lean during
wrestling season yes did I gain 30
pounds yes is it possible I gained
10 to 15 pounds of muscle probably I
would say that's more realistic
especially if you're newbie
um
I guess the first question that comes to
mind is like why do you want to gain 20
pounds of muscle maybe I should have
asked that but you're in you're 19 you
didn't mention any college sports or
anything like that and sometimes these
guys have this idea of like 20 pounds of
muscle is going to be what fixes
everything
and maybe it's more realistic that you'd
gain five in a year if you're natural
and even the first cycle I did of d-ball
deca and test low doses but still a lot
of you you know 25 milligrams to 30
milligrams of d-ball 300 Deca a week 250
test I run out like in like a few weeks
I gained 20 pounds now was it a lot of
water retention yes I think gaining
actual
skeletal contractile tissue is a much
slower process even if you do take
anabolics because part of this anabolic
steroid phenomenon is bringing water and
minerals into your body and glycogen as
well so those things are going to add
weight to you that is not necessarily
pure contractile tissue
uh
if you could see the difference between
somebody gaining five pounds of legit
muscle and losing five pounds or ten
pounds of legit fat you'd be pretty
shocked it's a drastic difference you
know and that's I think most guys are in
that zone of like you could make a big
change don't don't set I have to gain 20
pounds and then you know Jeff uh Saeed
recently talked about how he like dirty
bulked for like a year this guy was like
known for being really ripped and having
amazing hair he's like one of these OG
fitness model types amazing physique
always super lean year round
bulked for like a year and then cut down
and it's like his takeaway was you lose
most of the muscle you know so the
cleaner and slower you can do a bulk
you'll probably be more satisfied with
the results
is there going to be a slight like
benefit as far as like gaining muscle in
a certain amount of time if you quote
unquote bulk in a big Surplus yes
but then you have to lose the fat anyway
and so people if you're not
competitively bodybuilding to me the
answer is take it slower
um lift as heavy as you can and put
yourself in a moderate Surplus I
wouldn't do more than a thousand
calories Surplus you could probably get
away with three to five hundred calories
a day and uh and still keep it lean but
I'm talking to Isaiah recently he's
coming off of a contest and he's eating
like sometimes 3 500 calories a day he's
a small guy like 150 pounds he doesn't
look fat though because if you get super
lean first like I'd almost go like hey
cut down first and then slowly increase
your calories
um as you bulk from a point of leanness
and really monitor your body fat because
that's what like you're going to look
good anyway like if you bulk First
You're Gonna maybe lose some of your
aesthetic to like hopefully cut in the
future and then maybe you don't because
you don't want to lose a strength so
like a lot of people and this is another
thing that peanut butter recommends is
you lose all the fat first as much as
you can and then go from there so that
would be my recommendation I don't think
there's a you're not going to gain 20
pounds of pure muscle anytime soon take
it slow if you're Natty all right we
have so much fun stuff
um
Bro Science Academy you know one of my
clients sent me the other day with like
let's let's switch it up completely
let's do a chest workout that we've
never done before I'm like all right
[ __ ] let's do this
um you about to die no and what I did
was
first hit him with the decline bench
first hit him with the decline bench to
the beat guy Panther to keep my pen
um what if there was a rapper who just
talked about working out
he wouldn't sell a single album but I
would stream it uh the decline bench is
a great one because
it puts you in a mechanically
advantageous position compared to the
flat bench
I find myself lifting heavier and with
more control and actually getting like
you know people are like a bottle like
lower chest the flat bench really hits
your lower chest anyway and I've been
hyper aware of like the different
uh portions of my chest and what each
muscle does as I've had this like Peck
and shoulder issue because I'm trying to
like build up one side to the same as
the other and I always come back to like
man decline bench at this like this
strip of your PEC down here
um you know that connects like it's its
origin is right here and it comes down
and it's like right there
hitting that decline angle is essential
right and you don't want to exclusively
do that to the detriment of your upper
chest but like it needs to be developed
and I think the decline bench is
superior for essentially the entire
lower half of your PEC
um and just a better movement with less
stress on your shoulders in general and
a great like it just feels safer to me
when I do it I'm not you know you're
locked in with your legs you're not
bumping your ass off the thing it just
like overall especially for people with
shoulder issues it's a better lift and I
have a much better sense of like I'm
going to hit the next rep
um and it's also an easier position to
like grind through a rep
the next one would be weighted push-ups
I'm talking about just like having
somebody stack plates on your back okay
it's really underrated put two plates on
your back and see what happens right see
how many good form solid push-ups you
can do keeping a really strict plank
um it's underrated you'll see Chinese
lifters doing this a lot like because
they kind of don't really do bench press
as much like ask you know one of these
Elite Chinese weightlifters like how
much you bench like I have no idea but
they'll do weighted push-ups really
heavy dips
um deficit handstand push-ups Etc
the other thing would be a cable close
grip standing press what does that even
mean I don't know I kind of made it up
maybe other people do this but like
imagine your back is to this cable stack
the cable's going through your legs and
you have one of those it's like a row
attachment that you know is like a V and
then you have hand you have two handles
that are attached to the v
um locked in place
reverse that so you're kind of like
you're pushing it up right you have the
handles and it attaches down here
and you're standing straight up but
you're pushing up and out right so it's
like this close grip almost reverse it's
a close grip neutral
um chest pressing motion and I really
liked it I kind of came up with it on
the spot I'm like what I want to attack
this like motion where I'm coming up
with constant tension and not a barbell
and it actually really does work to like
activate certain portions of your chest
if you're going wide and you have like
being any shoulder issues it's just not
going to fire in the same way next thing
would be five second flat flies which
means you take a dumbbell you come down
and you do a five count each rep so
maybe you only get five right instead of
15 or something like that but the
tension in that stretch Position will
cause growth
decline dumbbell flies and depresses
another one like the decline benchworm I
start out I did five and five yesterday
so it's like heavy you know really
controlled really deep coming up really
feel it in that portion of your PEC then
when you kind of kind of fail at that
perfect form you bring it in to a
pressing motion but I also like I let my
scapula kind of come up to get that
stretch which also stretches your PEC
minor and then you press out of it and
then the final one is a peck scrunch
it's the opposite of a shrug so if
you're shrugging and pulling back with
your trap
you grab a dumbbell or a cable and kind
of like shrug but to the front of your
body you're activating these upper chest
fibers in an isolated manner oh I did
that and this is why we can't have nice
gyms
so this is another I'm doing a lot of
sketches I don't care
gym owner to the power lifter the power
lifter comes in and it's the kid and it
looks like he's just like smacking
flower everywhere right it'd be like a
power lifter
using chalk and I think that's why most
gyms Outlaw chalk is because people it's
just impossible to not make a mess this
guy I think is funny a lot of men are
confused by celebrities
um idolizing aren't always what women
are into in elementary school when every
girl was into Robert Pattinson my only
thought was this can't be possible he
looks nothing like John Cena
Yeah his ideas a lot of women a lot of
men are confused by celebrities that
women founded and I agree with this like
guys was like Pete Davidson it's like oh
right because you think like women can't
be attracted to anybody other than the
rock or John Cena and it's like no no
you're confusing you're homo eroticon
you're confusing your homoerotic
attraction with what women actually find
attractive and that's a fatal mistake in
your dating life now uh what's the next
one there
oh yes POV you come home from the gym
this guy's a great physique by the way
amazing quads to proceed to make
yourself dinner oh some nice chicken
rice and then after dinner
time for dessert and he eats his callus
oh yeah because you earned it
that's not ooh you grow you nasty
um and
oh darn it
that's okay we'll go to the next one
there was a deadlift faint it was
Private we're gonna get it next week
haters that's fake this guy's going for
it but it looks real to me like this guy
I think is doing the backflip on his BMX
lands it perfectly and we just got to
give it up to him people are always
going to try to discredit you speaking
of uh backflips I was at a wedding over
the weekend and I threw a backflip yeah
um you know was there a big pop
massive pop yeah big old pop but I did
kind of under rotate it and it looked
like I was gonna eat [ __ ] but I was able
to like turn it into a karate move oh
nice you saved it you were like yeah so
do we have video we do not didn't happen
you're right
no I'm dude people doing backflip like
it's amazing having seen Chappelle at
somebody shows now do backflips it's
like people just lose their mind like
you know it's funny when you know if
you're in a gymnastics uh you know gym
right it's like yeah yeah everybody can
backflip but if you're just a random guy
at an event it's like oh my God
Casey definitely got laid after that
okay
I'm not look I'm not gonna go into
Casey's personal life we can both just
cap this
understanding that it you know doing a
backflip at a wedding
it gives you opportunities to get laid
oh what's this next one what's this next
one Jim bro I have an idea um and
they're pouring all this water into an
entire tub of pre-workout and then
between you know two guys they're just
drinking it I assume this is uh Cali
mussels hyphy mud and you wonder why he
had a heart attack well this was
probably one of the small factors
contributing to that in addition to
Decades of anabolic steroid abuse but I
just I love this idea that it's like you
know like you need pre-workout we need
to like abuse that and it's like you
know or just or just work out right or
instead of just going like you know what
is pre what is the the heavy lifting of
pre-workout is the caffeine
drink 30 cups of coffee see how you feel
you know
um it chug an entire Folgers crystals
container see how you feel it's not
going to be good or healthy for you and
there is a curve to the sensation of
caffeine and you can also die like you
can you know you can a guy made his own
pre-workout I think we covered that at
some point and like 10xed it by accident
or whatever and it's like oops you know
um he died so be careful with that stuff
I'm gonna end on this
this guy has one leg and said can
finally squat 235 with one leg I don't
know his back story all I know he's got
a prosthetic leg he hits depth on this
235 pound squat
um
and it flashes to a picture of him as a
young kid I guess and he's going what
the [ __ ] we have one leg like bro tell
me it ain't true
um
but
when I see guys like that right you have
one leg and you're doing a 235 pound
squat which is you know that's a
respectable weight as a beginner with
two legs for sure
I go hey you out there
healthy guy in your 20s or your 30s or
your 40s who's not hitting depth on a
squad
what's your excuse because this guy who
has one leg could do it so I'm gonna
challenge all of my viewers to send in a
video to my Instagram of you hitting
full depth on squats and if you do that
I will feature you in a montage of an
upcoming episode
and make sure it's from the back so I
can see that peach you know what to do